what small act of kindness were you once
shown that you will never forget
wow that's a great question
you're you're you're i just wrote these
for the guinea pig you're at the guinea
that's great that's
this is where like workshopping
questions here all right i'll take it
now you're open biking yeah this is your
version um
let's see there's a couple ladies in
high school who were kind enough to hand
job me that was nice which i really
appreciate i don't think women know how
much that means to us you know when
we're like i'm not a piece of meat or
whatever and you're like i know but if
you just gave me a hand job yeah i would
it would make my world it's like telling
a kid he's smart or loved see most
people mention like a math teacher
middle school that that would inspire
them to get into science you you it's
you give a shout out to the well that's
part of that's not the nicest but i'm
just saying that goes a long way all
right uh let's see kindness that's a
great question
uh i want to give you a good answer i uh
i got lost when i was like six i was was
walking around my dad and i zoned out
and went away and
next thing you know i don't know where i
am i'm in a neighborhood this old guy
finds me crying on a lawn somewhere and
he goes uh come inside and he tried to
call my parents and nothing came of it
eventually they found me after like nine
hours cops were there the fbi's out
there [ __ ] helicopters
and i guess you know that's nice this
old guy took me in for a couple hours
and just sat me down and
kept me safe
that's something yeah oh how about anus
my transvestite
nanny very kind
he uh did you hear about this no okay we
had this transvestite nanny he was like
a drag queen but it was in the 90s so it
was weird it was new
and uh my bike got stolen and he you
know my parents were like yeah what are
you gonna do they're poor kids you know
and he was like [ __ ] it let's we're
gonna go get that bike and i was like
this guy's in a wig in high heels big
black guy and i'm like uh
ah what are you gonna do you know it's
gone and he's like nah we're gonna go
get it so we got in the van and drove
around my neighborhood saw the kids [ __ ]
with the bike you know five street tuffs
and uh he goes all right
you want to come out or should i just do
this and i was like you do it i'm
terrified what are you crazy
and he
got out of the van in full you know
heels and wig and he went up to these
guys and they went off oh my god look at
this [ __ ] guy homo [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] you know it's the 90s and he just
stared at him
long enough to where they were kind of
like all right well i guess we're gonna
fight you now and he goes uh that's not
your bike
and they go what are you gonna do about
it and he puts his hand on the middle of
the bike and they didn't do anything and
he just picked it up and said that's
what i thought put the bike over
shoulder slid the van door open threw
the bike in and we drove off
somebody stuck up for you yeah and you
know i mean he could have got i mean
their tools they could have [ __ ]
tuned him up two seconds
that actually like takes courage oh yeah
real courage and then that
the the reason you do an act like that
is that
makes a kid like you feel like
there's somebody on your side that's
possible someone on your side is big
it's big that goes a long way
especially when they have uh the risk of
getting their ass kicked or their job
taken away or whatever it is
you